In 2020, we made videos about.. the Game of
Thrones books, A Song of Ice and Fire – including
Euron’s apocalypse, the Dorne plot, and
Dunk & Egg.
We covered Westworld Season 3, and the new
Watchmen, and Raised by Wolves, and The Expanse.
We made a non-fiction video, about disaster
and religion and zombies.
And there was that Cookie thing.
In 2021, we'll keep making Song of Ice and
Fire videos – with more theories, recaps,
and analysis.
We’ll cover the Game of Thrones prequel
show when it comes, and hopefully someday,
we'll do The Winds of Winter too.
And we’ll keep covering new series – they’re
making a show of Foundation by Isaac Asimov,
so it’d be cool to talk about.
We could do some His Dark Materials.
Or American Gods, or The Boys, or more Expanse.
They're making shows of Sandman, and The Stand,
and Y: The Last Man.
There’s the Dune movie, and The Matrix 4
coming.
We could go back and do Dark or Devs.
And maybe more non-fiction videos, about history
and myth and stuff.
There’s a lot to choose from.
So we’re holding some votes on Patreon.
There’s one vote to choose a Song of Ice
and Fire video topic, and one vote to choose
a new series.
These votes are open to all Patrons on all
tiers, and the votes close in a week.
So for a few bucks, you can support Alt Shift
X, and help choose some new videos, at the
link below.
Either way, thank you for watching, and happy
new year.
Special thanks to Patrons Cameron Weiss, Michael
Appell, Ryan Steele, Triangle Wine Company,
Harry, Nikos Moraitakis, Shane Veglia, Brian
Sentient, Ria McDoodle, and Tim Cunniff.
Cheers.